so today is arena Kings this is my first
time playing in arena King season 4 I
think it started a few weeks ago I've
been so busy just haven't had a chance
starts in one second ok playing my wreck
us wrecker ass
let's play some opening by e6
whoa
it's bits thanks for the five hundred
bits heart why soon it'll appreciate
that I'm playing against a London and
place some normal line yeah I'll play
the Wesley so variation whoa you took
with a C pawn that's not so common
there's funds a bit tender and I'll take
I'll have the bishop pair so this is
three Oh meaning well Mickey are gifting
sobs to people thanks Mickey are gifting
subs to Fred the cat's matha juice son
something Gradius from Phil ish in
northern $9.99 really appreciate that
I played 95 I'll play 95 very soon I was
gonna say this is 300 which means time
is important let's play a 5 maybe
restrict any for ideas this looks very
similar to the game a Capablanca
Janowski if anyone wants to google that
there's a lot of similarities to this
position the block is gonna try and play
on on both wings
maybe someday g5g for it's a reasonable
move maybe I can take
hmm maybe Bishop Yeates I'm not sure
what to do about this Knights with an
IDF three on my play knight c6 or maybe
Knight B 3 an apology is the washing
machine is slightly in the background
but hopefully it's not too bad or not
the washing machine but the dishwasher
I guess the dishwasher is a washing
machine right let's take I played I want
to play b5 but doesn't feel right if
that for Bishop h5 check somewhat of a
spy check and thanks I'll forego for
subbing okay let's move my rook mmm what
- you may be king d8 threatening the
pawn defending the rook
I want to keep some time advantage this
could be a long grind maybe D for at
some point this should be five will
probably come so ticks ticks
yeah slightly annoying position play
this trying to leave some tension okay
now I'm slightly happier with c5 coming
you can't play b4 it's a 3G 4 is a good
move
let's take and play king g7 and maybe g5
some day like today
mmm
d4 ideas it's getting messy getting very
messy like the soccer player take mmm
let's play what did I play it may be the
smooth I'll maybe this move I'll just
trade everything cut-rate pawns this is
looking Josh draw
mmm there they're not worth it
yeah I mean this is d'etre
put the dishes on our five
Wow so he's trying to lose
oh no I dropped upon no you dropped a
bishop though what is this game what is
this game I'm winning somehow what is
this
Chuck Vance what was that what was that
game I wanted to draw somehow I won even
though I dropped up on okay let's play
on London such a messy game here's a
standing board my opponent is not alive
maybe are not here
also things W DW v DK for the sub and
hello to everyone else Kenda's first
time catching me streaming nice and the
ice and the chat yeah I'm in I'm in
America right now well I won a game that
was so much easier than the previous
game and thanks for the bits Birdman 500
bits
thanks Birdman alright let's play it
another let's play a nights tango I
played this in the st. Louis norm
Congress against Rochelle woo yeah III
is a decent move alright playing some
normal stuff this could transpose into a
hippo or King's Indian now we have some
Kings Indian structure so this move slow
down any be for expansion
and the Knight d7 5 ok very Kings Indian
like ib6 and maybe b6 wasn't necessary
play this trying to storm
so the goal is to just storm an attack
and eventually meets
it's interesting okay I'm still going
for the pond storm when does this move
well he wants to win d6 hmm so he's
threatening to take on b6 so maybe this
move looks ugly but I'm trying to defend
and I still want a storm
yeah let's defend some more maybe rook
and we got sevens bed push ticks ticks
Queen G for ticks
looks very risky
Keats yeah let's play King h8 looks slow
but I want to play this and not have to
worry about Bishop c4 he still plays it
g4 may be coming so I want to play
Bishop f6 and rook g7 and hope that he's
not promoting I might have to sack the
rook at some points 95s coming let's
play rook g7 and Bishop h4 Wow
they should be six that's old legal move
let's play maybe night h4 whoa
tix wait I can take here G file is
opening this is getting very messy
let's take here mmm
9h for a bishop maybe bishop here he
wants to do stuff
no idea what's going on
play that move first
oh dear takes Oh this is very bad what
do I do
I could take
I'm gonna be sucking everything
Chuck
yeah I'm actually like sacking
everything hoping that something is
working maybe f3 okay so I'm threatening
force me please don't see it please some
mercy he saw it let's play this
I have immaculate pawns but not for long
okay I resign
good game that was interesting it was
very uh I mean I was very sharp I was
hoping I would meet but I didn't mate
playing feather master let's play London
where is the standings Rena Kings
okay here's standings let's do this so I
want to play e4 yeah this is reasonable
f3
you guys playing a good line but it's
gonna be a fight okay there's a V - I
want to find 9 H 3 9 f 2
probably throw in King each one at some
points wants to play Knight h5 maybe f4
f4 there's B 4 so let's play Bishop d4 I
have the g5 square for the Knights which
could be nice
wow it's taken Queen d4 other than Queen
b6 it's flaking h1 first if he ever
castles I play Queen e1 at the pawn now
I play this
if castling maybe Queen e3 to h6 Knight
g5 have any merit maybe f4 here I'm
liking the position kind of have idea is
just improving let's start with this
might play nine eight four in China
trade Queens do I want to Queen trade
probably not this king is a bit more
suspicious
wherever the king goes there'll be some
potential to attack and I'm fine with
the double pawns shredder was his number
shredder 80 9100 with a sub I forgot
about B to do I care about be to kind of
I care more about the center I want to
play e5 very soon this night is a bit
stuck to there's nine eight four I'll
take it
Wow
who's this move let's play Knight d2 Wow
I'll post on b2 so if I play e5 he has a
night f5 fascinating let's play a3 just
want to under my knees pawns
okay now I can probably take okay we're
gonna trade Queens as my goal escape the
c3 is kind of weak of ideas over k3 and
taking a six is also kind of weak yeah a
96 defending threatening stuff let's
attack its attack upon first expecting
work c8 know maybe I should what should
I do here is this move
let's defend
I have a trick if Bishop e2 rook takes
I'd like g5
yeah let's see if he falls into it there
we go
that's a fork night and now c3 is
falling
this might stuck those Knights actually
now trapped you might play rook c8 but
then Bishop takes a six and now might be
pawns gonna run expecting like rook c7
I'll take he'll take my knight then I'll
push the b-pawn or I'll Fagin
interesting maybe I just defend the
Knights still trapped
oh he hasn't HC for a year oh that's
okay
okay I'll take upon
and push up on
well let's be careful I don't think I
care about that fawn maybe I do but
maybe I don't I'm coming for my own
attack well I got mated I got mated
I thought I saw a 92 I didn't see nine
h3 oh that's so bad that's so bad
I'm up a full/queen no that's game
I'm so bad okay
that's a wake-up call that's why you can
never get to relax
it's just way too relaxed sir yeah the
position is actually like I have to run
with my king and I should be okay oh
okay I need to drink this I need to
drink clear mind
kombucha I'm playing I'm playing the
same guy as last time I play him already
a whole long Greek name let's play tilt
opening okay I don't mind this he's
moving so fast I want to open up my
Kucha okay just please stop and think
for a moment it's a bottle opener broken
looks broken
wait so I'm doing a rolling unless it's
Kristoff
it's twist-off okay I was uh guess
importance to figure out let's put the
bishop here yeah that's reasonable let's
play d3 and move them to sit back Bishop
here Wow Bishop d2
so a main plan in positions like this is
just to attack with Athlon I play queen
h5 here oh no because it looks defended
so I'll play 9h three it looks very
strange but I want to play f4 f5
this looks playable f7 is going to be a
target
just pre-move everything actually if he
does that move whether I take on a
sudden first
all right so probably this move and have
a king's indian structure this time I'll
try and play it more effectively it
takes something here
Queen g5 King h1g sevens attacks
oh oh I forgot about that move wait but
I have Queen eight in the end this is
very tricky
there's also Knight takes g7 nothing's
quite working okay I'll have to go for
this Queen eight and then e five is
interesting
b5 takes he's gonna have f6 though
so maybe this first
I want to distract the bishop in min the
pawn okay that's a very strong move King
here ah he's gonna play off three but
after you have this move now this is
force mates well that's so sad
this is so so sad but I resign where's
the resign button oh there is okay this
is a rough start I won that first game
and then I just lost like three in a row
oh man oh but I won two games in a row
cuz of the one guy like didn't show up
okay so I have some hope I'm still
playing good place all right let's play
this move d4 bad move threatening the
snow I'm gonna pawn mmm
I mean Knight g4 how those white defend
f2 was looks very strong now d4 was a
little bit careless from wins so he
wants to wants me to take then Queen f3
so maybe Queen f6 just pile on f2 I have
three attackers and the king is the only
defender okay
I just want to win this game and get
back on track
is this kombucha with a lot of caffeine
brewed tea green tea organic rosemary
organic peppermints there's a lot of
like herbal type things I'm pretty sure
that is caffeine especially if there's
green tea in here so I can take on f2
will just take I'm f2 and go back now
this is a very nice position
if rook takes 95 pawn takes 95 this is a
fork Knights this beautiful nights
there's a g4 also on the horizon okay
kombucha saves a day so I don't know how
the scoring works I played like a lot of
these tournaments I still don't know how
it works I know there's some sort of
like streak thing which I don't have
currently ship g5 what do I play here
age six and then it's might be six okay
I think that plungers upon unless he has
a five now I'm winning upon okay this is
nice
let's play d6 okay just gonna try and be
solid the bishop back
feeling very comfy here just gonna play
bish about three probably oh just weave
in the chats what's up just weed let's
play this move don't you have to have
three to four consecutive wins yeah but
like you get some number of points
depending on how much or how many wins
you have in a row I think
okay White's trying to complicate things
a little bit you'll put the Knights
bring the Knight to f4 maybe
I could take on each for that's another
free pawn Wow
I played this move defends maybe it's
risky let's play this move okay now I
definitely want to Castle queenside and
use a G file to attack wait why not take
the free pawn I took two free pawns the
scheme is there a third three fine I'll
Castle queenside and this is looking
very nice wait everyone in the chat
saying why not take the free pawn I'm
pretty sure I already took it
this looks Pleasant because g2 is going
to be vulnerable like maybe the smooth
and I just opened up the bishop
probably this move defend b6o if takes
takes you can win the bishop and I win
the knight or the G to pawn it shouldn't
be ok up a little bit of time play it
safe for a little bit this looks like a
nice move because now the dial is gonna
open for me no matter what and this I
think this b4 move is a little bit too
slow maybe I'll take he's probably gonna
take ooh
so now I can take on c3 take on b4 stick
on b4 attack the Queen attack the Bishop
g2 Falls yeah everything was falling
apart for whites point system second win
in a row plus 3/3 or higher plus 4
points so can you get plus 5 points or
now you can only highest you can get is
plus 4 okay
next game so I need to win that was my
second win in a row so I need to win
another one let's play london again and
it says ten and number 35 so I'm in 35th
place I guess yeah I have a streak of
two interesting let's play c4 so this is
very typical London line play h3 I want
to play b5 now I want to bring the
knight here and attack the pawn
and take that
the interesting thing is that if I get
95 in black can't defend the pond so
he's sacrificing I'm gonna have that for
I'll put the knight on d4 try and be
solid while I think you 6
it was very interesting this is okay so
I want to play g4o he is Bishop e4
though if I play this sudden there's f5
this is very tricky it's like a castle
g4 Bishop b4 trick g1 takes off five
maybe I'll go for that
this Bishop will be dead in the end oh
he plays i-5 immediately
so maybe castling now he can't take
because I take and hit the O he could
gives it defense it's still very
interesting I'll put the rook on e1 I'll
go for a Bishop h5 very much of a fight
material is equal pawn structure is
really random yeah I think Trey the
light square bishop should be nice
especially if I can fix the pawns so I
want to get that 5 in still ideas of
night 85
hmm
let's play this first this is gonna
happen calf to defend
I think I like my chances because of
this move that the King here is gonna
play rook g8 and defend
maybe this moves looks very strange only
get my Knight to d6 hard to get there
though
maybe e6 maybe here and then here
hmm
it may be all in the c6 pawn we could be
trading see pawns or I'm not okay this
is beautiful square now those it defends
upon control so many squares in Black's
territory I'll play B for a five to go
for this
put the rook on b1 some amazing ideas
maybe that's a reasonable move let's
play this move
alright now I have to hold on to the
pong its play this move and check
while
okay this is looking very nice now raka
Pietro K 16 B 7 4 k 7q c 8 not going for
it alright let's play this move I want
to play rook B 2 and then just meet yeah
mate is coming I don't see how boxtops
it's a bishop e8 Rick here here my
bishop controls a7 okay that was nice
next game so I have a streak what you
needed streak I'm in 19th place I think
hello to people in the chat I'm drinking
kombucha suspicious tea yeah playing in
1800 and play a London I can't still
London okay this is a fun line the very
fun line it was actually very similar to
the structure I had last scheme a for it
doesn't seem right because of b5 this is
a pin I think I'm winning a pond
let's take it up put the bishop outside
the chain rookie five there's Bishop c7
I think I'll play it anyway Bishop c7 or
k-6 and the bishops a bit misplaced I
want to stop might be five
I'm probably King here if 95 we could
trade this mind is kind of annoying but
it's being tamed for the time being I'll
play this move 97 I'll just move the
rook you move the rook anyway alright
really liking the position now played b5
swallowed pawns ideas of rook b8 and b4
interesting let's do this
well
so let's take and play this and now I'm
gonna try and attack this pawn with
might be five and push this pawn
maybe someday Fork wow this might be one
move this move let's just attack the
pawn in the other time prepare a three a
two
get the other night into play
got the kingdom to play
yeah I'm gonna put the pollen III in the
king on a four and then double off on
the B file okay
nice game that was fun hey I'm playing a
GM been Feingold this name sounds
familiar
let's play chess I have a bad score
against him so let's try and take him
down he's playing a dubious like Tori I
have to flag him according to boat as
he's old and slow those are not my words
oh all right I'm playing solidly at
least trying to keeping the bishop hair
let's oh let's not castle because
there's Forks ah let's play this move
hey it's caring in the chat what's up
Karen Karen you should be playing this
event too let's play this move let's
play this move
oh man he wants to like destroy me I
think this is okay
I'll have Bishop f5 King h8 then we'll
play f6 and destroy his dreams f6 coming
BAM
and then II 5 coming oh he wants to meet
me though
maybe g6g 6 looks wrong maybe queen bee
7 also looks wrong what do I do here
g5 like a G that looks wrong as well so
probably this move I want to play e5
maybe this move wait the bishops trapped
the bishops trapped he's gonna play e4
maybe but I won't be winning upon I
think whoa he's sacking material okay so
I'm up material I have the bishop hair
and he has a singular Bishop I wanna
play this and then this and be happy
retreat always retreats and retweets
okay attack the bishop what does he okay
he still wants to destroy me
let's do this strong bishop being
influenced by the sky I wanna play rook
out five kick this guy away he's
trapping my bishop what no wait maybe Oh
No
how's he trapping my bishop maybe I can
shot no Brooke Bishop d6 is coming
take sticks let's do this
how do you try my visit
I have to be very careful here he's
gonna play Bhishma for I don't know why
he's thinking it was a very scary
position for both of us
but as time is dwindling g5 ideas
is he okay slightly concerned for him
that he's like Karen are you distracting
him
I think Karen's distracting him Bishop
d6 what's Bishop d6 I can take and then
take he's alone win my SI phan or not
bishops move backwards
ah does this move takes
probably this move okay there we go I
feel safe now kind of move here okay
this is where I have to show my speed
and my past months soon to be passed
pawns look okay oh he almost Queens
hello Ben scary
good game Ben I think that's the first
time I ever beat him not sure our score
though that was slightly scary alright
back to London I'll play Brad didn't
bother I have a streak when was the last
time I lost a game I can't even remember
I think I suppressed all the memories
just probably a good thing Queen b6
interesting
yeah his rating is slightly scarier than
his opening wait am I just winning here
how does he stop this move he can't play
96
I don't think Alice looks very pleasant
you might play a six maybe six looks
playable and then we'll trade I'll still
be happy though Wow was this move I
played this move I want to play a five
okay things are gonna settle down I
think maybe maybe ticks
yeah Bishop e5 coming now this is a very
very nice
opening so a6 was reasonable let's play
this move if all the minor pieces
developed he winds up on really so you
want to pawn but not really
this is winning a bishop okay that was
nice
[ __ ] miniature man the ratings keep
increasing for my opponents play qgd
and we'll have some slow opening I'm in
third place I'm in third place
hey that's nice okay I'll try and keep
up the streak so this is still theory Oh
for rougeau right above me okay still
theory yeah that's a move I want to play
c5 someday
boy what night b1 when does an IP one
yes it's playable and just want to put
my pieces on good squares nothing
special
maybe night before coming
if efore than d3 is loose
it's interesting move can take a lot of
stuff here a let's take and maybe Queen
B seven
put the Queen on the side have ideas of
this listen mate
but the rook on the a file first
yeah this is probably some idea it's
probably going to take on F 609 f3
ideas of c-4 someday
I still want to play c4 someday
play h6 stop Knight g5 stuff make moved
for the King I won't play c4 and Bishop
c5 be nice I think it's gonna happen
because this is these are two very juicy
targets and this is also two juicy
targets so there's four juicy targets if
I can do math now b4 is coming the
bishops gonna be put in jail and it
didn't even get to Pascoe all right now
the night will come to d5 probably ooh
he wants to do stuff on f7 let's do this
move and g4 doesn't scare me too much
I just want to take 95 and be up the
piece so the bishops just out of play
okay now I can take an 85
where is my discovery
maybe this move if efore and I thought
for is nice B threes loose also the time
is kind of flagging mm-hmm threatening
me if Queen f29 h3 what's a nice finish
alright I'm increasing rating I'm
increasing my place the tournament I
have a street of seven wins nice I'm
still in third place playing a fan
Nagoya or Magua let's play another in
London play this before
MF three
yeah this is some line
wait what but I can do this right takes
yeah this is fine worried about d4 for a
moment there don't entirely know the
theater here and takes an F for some
interesting ideas
ooh that's not good let's do this move
first
could we have 695 couple targets
so I could take on the c7 just be upon
this looks nice f-for coming
ah that's a good move this East six
where looks so juicy let's just put the
rock in the center everything's still
defended the king might be a bit loose
maybe this check
wait I'm winning my winning pawns so I
have 9 f4
hmm oh wait I am winning pawns so I can
take your first and then d6 is also
loose so okay I'll take here
now I win d6 probably this move
yeah 52 saves the day all right that was
nice
all right I'm in second place man all
right let's play another in London
openings doing well okay so same line as
last game each five
what are these people playing h5 don't
understand this move this block probably
is not castling you're probably going
for d5 let's play Knight h3 maybe Bishop
d3 eight years of e5
maybe ideas of t5 as well I want to
trade Queens probably not those kings in
the center he wants to play Knight b6 to
c4 okay maybe I do want to trade Queens
changed my mind
yeah well Trey and Bishop gypsy 1 I'm
still a little bit scary yeah let's play
Bishop c1 I'll be bring the knight
closer to the center yeah there's some
attack for black it should be okay
g4 ideas
so we're both trying to attack without
Queens at probably taking an a3 pretty
standard way to close down the position
would be three is a slightly weak and
this move attack the b-pawn
ah this is a fight I'm very much of a
fight take with this pond I'm gonna play
g5 and push the H pawn I have worked g3
ideas looks nice Knight a5 I just want
to win the b-pawn he wants to play c5
which is tricky I can take its like
Bishop is a very tricky position let's
play less the c5 now I take so he still
wants to play c5 but the knight a 4
let's play h4 entirely sure what's going
on here it takes
hmm
yeah I'm not so fond of my position
anymore but I'm still alive you can't
take on c5 because b3 I think h5 ideas
will not bring the knight to d3 but not
easy to do any ideas of g5 then h5 let's
put the bishop here defend the pawn
Knight a5 was questionable
see two's week
Brooksie cheer up d - that's interesting
works here each one
I'll stick the knight in here
I'll play h5 yeah he can't take it cuz I
have four oh he can
oh he's meeting me what no forgot about
that
okay let's try him in this pawn still
kind of I'm not really a fights
going for last tricks still really
trying
yeah so sad
ah good game well played that was
difficult I tried okay if I'm playing a
little red player I'm still in I'm still
in third place
what nice let's play c4 to get back on
track where's standings I'm still wait
I'm still in second place Oh tight for a
second f6 is very strange
oh I could have taken the bishop I so
can take the bishop this is winning now
rook is trapped this is what I need just
quick rebound he's gonna try and trap my
Queen feel a little bit careful here
maybe c5 c5 first please c5 first Queen
d7 here I'll take I'll take on a 6b out
material
you'll have a no Queen a six or Noah 96
now let's try and rescue the Queen but
how
maybe this move mmm I forgot about that
it's still okay I still have two works
for the Queen she works on the pawn for
the Queen
everything's defended I think let's play
this move that's slightly annoying I'll
have to live with it I want to bring the
knight here maybe a bishop here I just
want to chase away the Queen from b4 and
then get the b-pawn rolling monkey for
tricky
oh this is bad just gave away a pawn for
nothing
nexi - maybe night see to play this
first
man what's going on
wait am i winning material Bishop g4
truck g19 h6 could take on h4 then
f 3 coming
I'm gonna be safe blocks my G file that
boxes Queen let's play B for some if I
wanted to play for a while probably rook
H one at some points let's play f4 lock
things down I'm feeling comfortable kind
of
should have three baby coming
still looks okay
kinga safe
defend the pond
hmm I'm feeling uncomfortable this move
I guess
Queens infiltrating that's really
annoying
I guess this move I have to pray that
everything is defended
Eirik C 1 multiplied b5 Queen d2 b 5
take sticks could be upon race my time
is so low though
okay at least he's thinking now
okay that's a good sign
let's play rook let's take that first b3
maybe rippy six knows no draw you
offered me a job
I think oh shoot I should have not taken
that okay this is war
wait oh he moved okay thought it was pre
moving okay I won the game
yes I'm playing hozier doll or was your
daddy let's play play this line we have
a four Knights copy catch us still in
second place still copy catch us
okay this line um this move in t5 coming
fifty-two minutes left in the tournament
weight chest craft has is 13:46 how is
he in first place just playing lower
here the players should have a solid
hold half open file kind of nice I just
hang upon I could take with Queen not
the most aesthetic move but I defend the
pawn I control the center well I also
play 94
maybe you see five years of c4
yeah okay
hey this is a smooth trend meek
94 take sticks at five ideas of pawn
takes Queen d4 if the upon takes windy
for maybe rope ta come in
that's a reasonable move let's not trade
Queens only get the rook to d8 I also
want to play c4 man low rare the players
are just crashing this tournament let's
play the smooth
hey Guiness man with a sub I have not
been reading sub names or looking at the
chat much thanks for thanks to mods for
being in the chat I'll look after the
tournament let's play brook g6 there's
nine of five played Bishop c6 within
Queen e6 okay let's play a so I want to
play a four
yeah he's moving kind of slowly stick we
could be trading I'll have Bishop a6 in
the end I wanna see five fine okay
I was expecting Queen takes d3 this
looks very pleasant because this is a
huge weakness rook da coming in from d1
if Brooke c1 we could trade stuff or
maybe just queen bee for still week and
he's a long time so I want to keep
tension in the position if not five
maybe I can like take on e4 okay ticks
hmm he's gonna win the pawn
so maybe this move looks weird but I'll
play c5 soon maybe leave that was bad
but I still have a time advantage and
try and use it as a weapon g6 ideas
Queen takes you for ideas
Bishop's you hate ideas I have ideas
well can I take a pond and that's free
looks nice
yeah weights gonna flag
okay nice game second plane I'm playing
a new person t3 t3 is kind of passive Oh
try and play actively I'm in second
place still tied for first
mmm let's not blender stuff it looks
very questionable for whites but maybe
it's playable how do I make progress
maybe d4
put the Queen on c5 interesting Square
create the battery and the tin battery
pen thread is to take or maybe night
before and I want to play b5 can I take
first or b5 first maybe b5 first
it's interesting position have some time
advantage
a three could be interesting a three
takes before okay here I just went upon
oh there's meeting ideas well does this
position I have let my guard down takes
e4 maybe what is going on no idea what's
going on he's gonna take on e6 takes
take sticks I'm down the pawn but I have
Center pawns in the end it's so
complicated
oh my Brooke is hanging no at least I'm
attacking a pawn
it's still interesting I have a big time
advantage okay no I can do him oh no
he's forking me this is stuff happening
so let's not give up just yet so I can
take let's take care first I have a big
clump of Center pawns that maybe has a
future but maybe not play this move
let's move
I want to push pink down the rock does
this work
this works cuz this check wait I'm
coming back I'm alive I'm not dead yet
it's a miracle am i up now I can't even
count the pawns I'm up a pawn I'm up
upon H five I have three Center
beautiful punching okay let's move I
have to be careful still let's move this
way
be very careful just pawn is scary
hmmm how am i alive it's like being dead
and I'm coming back to life
okay let's check first
maybe a five I want to keep everything
defended now he's gonna win the pawn
wait what's going on at 44 before
and then look t5 I check in d3 and when
that fond this is winning
let's better be with it wait take and
then push the Kings too far away
this crazy position crazy game next
match playing cilok feel like I've
played salak before London opening again
so I have a streak under disky past me I
it was H 5 H 5 is silver anthem this is
a week mmm it's interesting though this
looks playable for a la play C for ABC 5
looks nice use of night power
in Queen B 3 first yeah a night power
this looks very nice so where to put the
night probably this car
what to do maybe this funny ideas of D 5
D 5 e 5 so maybe f 3 always playoff 3
and G files open if you take so I'll
probably take with rook just activate
the pieces okay this looks nice still
take some work bf 4x4 Knight g4 h 3mm
and f7 so takes
looking for tactics
looks so close Bishop c4 takes takes
rook h6 and end and rookie and that
looks so so close so there take six for
gage 648 b6 Bishop e6 okay I wouldn't
that fun yeah I'm gonna simplify to an
end game maybe not the best decision
whoa wait
this looks wrong let's take check
maybe check first or takes first and
then 56 this is gonna hang my kings
defended I spent a lot of time but I
think it was worth it
Nene for I just queen up six if this
probably this moves so many ideas Turkey
it would be nice okay Oh people are
passing me
and these GM's have to catch up
have a little bit of cooldown
okay next match hey second place again
47 points the Bojan let's play this
opening I'm being aggressive being very
aggressive
that was very tricky opening yeah that's
a reasonable approach but is it you can
play this or some Bishop d6 videos let's
play this first made it bishop okay
take that
maybe I'll just move back
yeah I can't complain with opening up
the Queen here
this looks reasonable
he's gonna win g4 unfortunately but it
should still be playable at this 55
ideas maybe Bishop h4 I just want to
take and meet on h2 also d4 is of the
tender its Castle SC 3 expected
quindi three ideas interesting in G five
ideas
clayji five because I don't know what
else to do
that's still interesting I have bishops
here's an extra pond
I'd like to exert more pressure on the
h-file Wow okay let's play this move use
of g4j tanks let's take first
t5 is coming
maybe f5 we can trade then play d5 and
Bishop here it's still interesting it's
probably a good move and play this yeah
the G file opens that'll be heaven it's
probably not happening he's gonna take
on c7 I can play King take c7 stayin
alive the Queen trade will come at some
points not sure who will initiate it
he's getting low in time
okay now probably should trade Queens
control the e-file maybe in g4
have to keep the time advantage the most
important factor oh it's not allow forks
taking a lot of time let's play this
Bischoff always control the g8 so I
think he's just going to fly
oh no oh wow
he had point one seconds he could have
pre move Queen a5 but Wow
I was 0.1 seconds away from losing that
game okay
ducks gain oh that's very close
oh he almost won that okay on the game
so I'm still in third place for who's
leading now playing the same opening
playing a lot of similar openings today
94 84 a good move yeah d4 is very strong
against this opening
I think it's still somewhat playable
wait g3 g3 I can take and Queenie for
this is one of the main traps like he
played what should be the refutation but
I think this is now getting complicated
yeah always playoff six
it's gonna play like Queenie - and take
on that six and it's gonna be a mess you
can't just take back what's the scariest
discovered check Bishop no he doesn't go
for it
maybe if it should be seven queen d5
coming tack a 2 and this should be six
King be one digit e6 well alright let's
probably take care first forgot taking
on a - doesn't really have a threat cuz
might be one
mm-hmm
it looks okay looks a little bit cheeky
ooh eh three ideas oh this is not
pleasant
king of sudden
speech three f5
I'm still somehow surviving
it's taking a lot of time but my
position is very shaky so maybe this
move over then Queen h5 coming so I can
take and still queen h5 like we a tribe
King G you okay
I think I'm alive still time is ticking
there's 5-7 to g6 maybe keep me safe but
the night is gonna come in was very
scary
maybe at five
if I looks wrong let's
or to do H 5 H 5
okay I'm cocooning very deep strategy of
building a cocoon
it's playing this
well f6 is hanging we even take it I
take and Queen g7
okay I still have time I wrote to you
one no can't play Ritchie one just yet
let's take here to attack the Queen get
some counter play well this is oh this
is a nice idea rook g1 I take it you
didn't fall for it so let's play virtue
to broken g3 there's math for ideas
pin and wind or pin and flag let's play
the smooth yeah probably a pin in flag
b5 always play b5
oh I hung up thing oops
oh man I'm hanging things no so dirty
[ __ ] him now let's play this move oh
that's check I forgot I was Chuck
so bad
okay I feel dirty but it took a lot of
time there all right I'm still in third
place I'm playing who's your daddy
Oh who's your daddy I get it very clever
okay we have an opening another London
opening whoa its bits from WV dk8
896 it's two this
probably could have like d5 there hmm
play this move and use of 95 or night c4
now this is very tricky as blacks not
preparing stretch ok night c4 is nice
defend attack Queen before I have c3 and
I'm the Queen's actually trapped have
you moves back and I just probably take
the pawn this actually looks very nice
and give up the bishop area but he six
there's 96
yeah that's reasonable I want to play
Queenie - in 96 mate hmm it's hard to
make happen
yeah let's just develop normally Castle
kingside
keep a time advantage
maybe c3b for some day he's probably
gonna play b6
toxic on b5 yeah yeah we can trade
reasonable position he has a bishop pair
of a pawn and I have time
it'll play like a three h3 just easy
quick moves cuz thanks for subbing hmm
maybe Queenie to just to avoid any
bishop ASIC stuff
if d6 I have to play Knight g4 oh then I
lose be too but then I maybe when he 7
it's complicated I think that actually
is okay for me oh I my Knights I forgot
my Knights not defended their oh man so
I have to go for another D dirty flag
I'm up a minute on the clock unfortunate
take
we'll play e6
I'm gonna move the night to each five
interesting
it's play Queen f3
I want to throw pieces of the kingside
I have to defend pawns first he's very
long time
like I actually like my chances to win
this it's no increment whoa does that
work I guess I kind of works
hmm takes throwing some check it doesn't
work
I think again I mean there's works um
one maybe Rick see one
ID 4 is gonna hit me but I have no h5
coming
what's going on here
Wow
huh who's your daddy okay Gigi oh man
chess is complicated and sometimes dirty
I have a streak I have a seven game
streak again mom it's focus I'm playing
a 16-11 well let's go for the kill let's
play this line let's Steve five line is
fun sometimes whoo this is very fun d3
is very weak
yeah Bishop f1 that's probably the best
approach it's a very pleasant position
though
yeah I'm just gonna like slowly build up
and then go for some later attack it was
very pleasant position to play maybe
some ideas of f4 eventually maybe start
with g5 else ideas of lifting
yeah I just want a lift bro your gauge
6if h4 probably rough g 6v g 5y a g5
such a nice smooth g5 is always a nice
move now the H file is open in ideas of
rook h6 Queen h5 and mating whoa I take
with knight or bishop maybe bishop
there's a little play Queen d1 slightly
annoying
I'll probably play Queen f7
hmm
oh this is gonna be nice I'll take on f4
does that work taking on that for I
think that works f king up
oh no it doesn't work if you stopped
Bishop to c4 so let's go for the check
yeah I still take some work
I mean Black has full control white has
like no breakthroughs I don't think
maybe this idea I'll try and bring the
bishop to f3 then there will be more
clear amazing ideas by threading Queen
tags g2 I'm threatening Queen tangs g2
with force mate please allow it this is
like a actual bow test gambit
actually no it's a fake book test
gambits okay good game that was a nice
finish Queens up
all right the cheese guy or the chess
guy why that I think cheese let's play
you six okay I'll play at this line B
five before I mean oh I'm right behind
four Rouge probably include a five never
mind play ninety-six
some interesting opening
a half-open B file will see threatening
Knight g5 I think he was threatening my
g5 there it was very tricky threats okay
let's keep the bishop hair ideas of
night b4 there's a Queen's tied down to
the night yes my queen b1 or not let's
just take a free night this is where
people get sleepy I'm not getting sleepy
I have kombucha wide-awake see you in
the resign am i trapping the Queen
somehow like this move
how does he escape all these squares are
controlled my bishop defends backwards
I still have kombucha looking at rocks
thanks for subbing also fnatic chess
thanks for hosting appreciate that it's
a nice position I in first I'm in first
place 67 points nine game streak there's
13 minutes left
mmm alright London time again you six
let's play chess and b6 let's play 95
he's gonna play f5 f6 Wow play this move
I think the idea here when they put the
pawn on f5 eventually I'll play like
rook d1 and c4
try and destabilize black setup yeah I
saw and routine do this once I wasted
time but he also wasted time that's a
reasonable move that's a little bit
uncomfortable maybe now I'll play this
okay feeling comfy I could take can play
at for maybe four looks nice I want a
castle and then someday play g4 nice X
97 that's what's castle at c3 should be
stable
maybe Bishop II one at some point
there should be one g4 until late Rob
let's take with this pawn have that file
open
ideas of Brooke b2 as well
what to do your okapi - now let's flip
the bishop my bishop belongs on f4 to
move it back
mmm good challenge the P file maybe I'll
put the Queen on C - you want some plain
8/3 yeah it's a bit annoying take sticks
and my bishop was just stuck
I'm gonna do this and then
I still want to play g4 I have this
battery now like g4 here each three
first he's gonna play queen a3 and rook
up to Bishop a4 queen c1
okay G far I still want to play
this Bishop is kind of stuck on b1 it's
gonna play Queen c7
so maybe Queen C 2 and G for coming
group b 8g for Queen b6 work F 1 Queen B
- maybe I win a pawn or at least
activate they should yeah expected line
yeah I should be winning that five fun
or not it's interesting move maybe takes
and Queenie - I do have Queen h5 this is
gonna get messy I have a time advantage
i 5s attacks currently Wow what does
this move King each - just gave away a
queen I have this move maybe taking it
first I'm gonna win g5 yeah this should
be completely winning okay let's take
here it's no threat yet I'll win the g5
fun
bring the King to f4
or I'll just flag them
all right that was nice next game David
something okay new game playing a
Knights tango I played this against
Rochelle rule recently I think I played
this once before in the tournament I did
a bishop before and yeah with the slime
idea is taking this and this
some Kings Indians structure maybe this
move looks fun
hit the Queen hit the Knights this
actually looks very unpleasant for once
queen d3
maybe rook here I'll probably keep the
bishop oh can I keep the bishop yeah I
can't because a knight takes our
favorite d4 maybe no just move it back
if 94 I take and play Bishop d4 yeah
bishops very nice in this position a5
ideas may be 66 ideas - just want to
open the center I take we can I take
three times and play e4 and then let's
take here first looks so close to
working I think he has Queen g3 then I
take takes takes Knight takes d5 takes
there there
let's go for it's relying on intuition
the only issue is this Jeep on but
Queens III I take with check I hope I'm
not miss judging because I have six
maybe it's just trading a lot he's gonna
win d3 but my rooks are a bit more
active
so let's play this move turning Bishop
e2 also ideas of skewering the queen and
rook okay so he stops it kind of late
over okay one doesn't work so let's play
this move connect the rooks ideas of
Bishop f5 hit the Queen
maybe this move whoa it's bit it's a
thousand bits from what's your name Sam
tan
Big Sam tan wait is this winning this
looks winning Bishop d3 coming
those were good luck bits I appreciate
this man
okay next game 75 points Lenderman right
behind me playing I am Jack Rogers
is he an I am or it just says his his
name I am there's four minutes left
we're playing online let's play Knight
b5 this could be the last game it's very
pleasant opening those are very very
pleasant yeah p3 this very typical idea
of black and trying with a pawn but it's
not gonna last
let's try this ideas a 95 or 92 or queen
a4 and Queen a4 is simple
oh there's a 95 idea to soil for black
so let's start with this wait this is
like in my London course where the idea
is to Lowe's idea taking and Queenie -
pretty sure this is a tactic in my my 8
hour video course
I don't know if it's this exact position
but it's very similar because I if he
takes on c4 I win the exchange if he
doesn't I'll have 96 ideas this should
be good
maybe 6 9 is doing nothing yeah that's a
good move I still have to be careful
we bishop eat oh no there should be two
ok queen takes you to Bishop f3
if b5 ok that's some move - so let's
just Castle and simplify well I forgot
about that move I play ninety five
ninety five is okay because takes takes
I might be down upon but I have massive
initiative because bishops oh my gosh
okay I have to win in like twenty more
seconds how free Bishop nice I have to
win before this tournament ends
he's just resigned oh no I can also it
it's so bad
oh my gosh I'm losing now draw I freaked
out because the time situation oh no
that's so unfortunate
mmm listen there's a minute left in the
stream am I still in first place I'm
still in first place how do I draw this
let's do this let's do this
mmm let's do that
tricky move wait did he fall for my
trick think he fell for my trick oh he
didn't fall for my trick
can I take I could there any still
matrix here no I just draw have I draw
accept hey I want to read the Kings by
one point that was a somewhat anti
climactic finish i finished ahead of
hanson man what is this hell I win the
tournament I had such a rough start I
was getting like smashed all over the
place it was like a rosin smash man
opposite direction but then I came back
I had some nice streaks some interesting
games thanks people in the chats oh man
so much supports Braden Laughlin who are
these people a lot of new names thank
you everyone
chest me in the chat a draw did it
wait did drawing win me the tournaments
did the draw count one draw I think the
draw may be finished
I don't know so confused thanks for the
bits whoever cured this there are so
many things I missed like throughout the
whole event
I was nice I was my first arena kings
like this season 777 bits from Lulu Lulu
food thanks Lulu food oh man so many
people here pasta bomb thanks for
subbing and thanks for the more bits you
can check your archive to see if the
draw counted yeah I did the draw count
how do I go to my username username yeah
the other
games oh it did counts wait how many
points does a draw get me in the
tournament
did it really count I think it counted
and it was crucial to pass Slenderman oh
man one point I clicked it with like a
second a split second left - someone
needs to clip that okay that was nice it
was fun
Turner's pondering sander thanks for
subbing oh man what just happened I want
arena kings look at all these people
that I passed nerd Itsuki and these are
like all my idols in chess too bad
NACA's not here actually a good thing
not cuz it's not here because I would
not have won this tournament if naka was
playing most likely things are the bits
tog e7 more cuz you did not see the foe
you cheered 500 before yeah thank you
everyone for cheering and following and
subbing and just wishing congrats and
flame emotes I'm not a GM yet but I
won't crack you too often if you if you
miss speak Oh Grisha it's not here
either
ah yeah they're like playing in Russia
or something man
oh that was fun tournament what do I do
now